president Trump's revived travel ban
goes into effect at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
time tonight it's going to affect
travelers from six mostly Muslim
countries for 90 days there will be some
exceptions but visa applicants and all
refugees from those countries must have
a close family or business tie to the
United States Jan Crawford has the fine
print from the new rules that the
Supreme Court allowed this week Jan good
morning
well good morning David so you know I
mean they say that the Devils in the
details so what exactly is a close
relationship we've now got some guidance
from the State Department and they're
saying that a close family relationship
includes a parent spouse child or
sibling already in the United States but
grandparents grandchildren aunts uncles
other extended family members those are
not considered close relationships and I
think that's where we may see some
litigation if for example a grandchild
is denied a visa now when it comes to
business ties the State Department says
a close relationship there must be
formal documented and formed in the
ordinary course rather than for the
purpose of evading the ban the ban also
may not apply to people who have
previously established or significant
business contacts with the US so that
means journalists students employees
lecturers who have valid invitations or
work contracts in the US would be
allowed as well as people who are
traveling with a recognized
international organization now visas had
already have been approved those
reportedly will not be revoked and the
guidelines also make other exceptions
for infants adopted kids and people who
need urgent medical care and the
justices well they're gonna hear
arguments on this ban in the fall to
consider where there all of this is
constitutional Nora all right Jim thank
you so much